hello friends and welcome to a very
special launch day stream i'm daniel
dwyer sitting here at my dumbass fallout
4 xbox one pad uh playing five four on
pc it's out tomorrow there's a bunch of
people that like to play today embargoes
are done 9 out of 10 on gamespot.com uh
and we've had access to it uh most of us
in the staff here for over a week so
i've been playing quite a lot of it so
to i guess in picking where to go from i
wanted to keep this as spoiler free as
possible uh while also i guess showing
more than the first three hours of the
game which is basically what everyone's
doing today so where i'm at now is about
let's say
over 10 hours into the game on this save
um
i got this lady who's wearing this sweet
let me get rid of her
gun situation we're in a sweet getup
does not look like she's super tough
actually i usually have this uh
this gas mask on
oh man you're going to get used to these
menus they are real son of a [ __ ] yeah
that's my lady she's killing it
and i've rolled a couple of different
characters currently playing this on pc
i know with the controller but
i've been playing all weekend sitting on
my couch so uh okay happy to report at
least that it runs uh super good
uh on pc and uh with a controller it
doesn't look super amazing this is not
the highest graphical settings but it's
pretty much up there
but yeah for the next hour or so i'm
gonna spend the next
while i guess
exploring the waistline showing you guys
some side quests trying to keep it
spoiler free as possible and uh keeping
an eye on both of the chat rooms i've
got gamespot and twitch chat right up in
front of me here and this isn't max
graphical settings we can only stream in
720. so
it's at 60 frames a second it should be
anyway um
and i think everything's set up
generally everything's set to um high or
medium on this machine mostly high
and then
i think medium for a couple of texture
setting stuff
and i've already cleared out this
building
of uh
of jerk holes
so i'm gonna use i don't want to show
you guys this because it's gonna
keep you away from spoiler spoilers
but once we get outside i'm gonna ask
the twitch chat what direction we want
to go in once i show you my map
the one thing i will say is that that's
really good about this game a little bit
jottery actually at the moment i don't
know what that's about um
is the lighting is super better on pc
than it is on a playstation 4 and xbox
one frame rate's better too obviously
and it looks a lot better but the
lighting especially i found the console
versions look pretty flat
anyway let's go outside
yeah no silly pip-boy thing sadly i'm
not playing my pip-boy edition isn't
arriving until tomorrow but you can
still do it if you just download that
fallout 4 app thing if you want to
get involved in that madness
all right so here we are so
the map currently looks like this
uh i'm in the middle of town diamond
city is here this is basically the main
boston area in terms of city
up here is cambridge which is another
town you sort of make your way through
in lexington and you start up in the top
left corner here
now the weird thing is you kind of in
this game unlike three and new vegas you
start out like basically inside suburbia
moving towards a city really quickly and
then you're in sort of
like i don't know built up urban areas
relatively quickly so i was kind of
worried when i first started playing
that this game doesn't have big open
wastelands but man it does over here
this whole area is full of super high
level
[ __ ] who are just wandering around
lots of like scorched trees and stuff i
have not been down here at all i don't
know what's going on in here
uh i've got about 10 hours on this save
and i've i've got about 10 hours on a
different save and another save after
that with five
and i still haven't made it down here
and then this is a whole weird situation
as well this is all irradiated so
there's loads of places to uh
to explore and wander around
uh right off the bat so i guess where uh
where'd you want to go let's write some
ideas there in the chat um and let me
know uh i think i'm gonna wander this
area up here is just a nightmare so i
don't really want to
get stuck in here anymore i've got loads
of quests because i kind of wandered in
stupidly to make my way over to this
spoiler area over there
uh but this area right here is not so
bad actually i might maybe i might
invade
trinity plaza you kind of come across
that pretty early so let's
let's do that i'm going to walk there
actually so you guys can see some of
boston
with my trusty
this is a sweet gun i got a bunch of
guns
but i'm like hot swapping between them
at the moment because
of ammunition so i got oh so many
fragments i used to have loads of
missiles but i found this massive beast
that i had to dump 15 missiles into so
i don't have any missiles anymore and
got some pistols
got a nuke mine
this sniper rifle i just picked up is
not too good
and
i think one of the biggest difference
between this and the previous fallout
games is that the customization on some
of this stuff is crazy like muzzled
powerful 10 millimeter auto pistol so
that basically means that somebody's
taken this regular 10 mil pistol
uh
and done a bunch of mods to it which is
why it's got this little
glow side thing on it as well
and you can mod them as well
as you go but you'll find a lot of
unique pistols not so much like
borderlands but like definitely on that
scale
this is a pretty standard ass shotgun i
got four rounds for that
pistol is pretty good and then you stick
up the you got your little inventory
here on the right which you can that was
obviously in previous fallouts but
they've kind of expanded it a little bit
so i go between the rifle and this
incendiary pistol quite a lot this thing
just
straight up sets [ __ ] on fire
it's pretty good
but for kind of walking around i like to
use this because 10 mil ammo doesn't
cost that much and once you start
leveling up and getting your like
your shooting accuracy up then the feral
ghouls start to drop pretty good after a
couple of shots of this thing so that
ain't so bad
uh
yeah all right
i'm gonna wander on down
through some of boston hold on b
of course you could turn on your pip-boy
light way light brighter than previous
games
way greener as well of course you can
change your hood color i don't think it
changes the lamp color actually that's i
kind of want to check that out now
let's do let's make it a little bit
bluer
i like a blue
there we go
no
maybe if i change the hood
this is super granular probably
shouldn't be starting with this but what
are you going to do
hood or posse here we go
make a green
yeah there's that blue that's what i
like
yeah the light totally changed the light
totally changed
all right let's make the dumbest i gotta
i gotta figure this out
it's all about expert this game is about
discovery
even if that means discovering stupid
options which shouldn't mean anything
can i make this pink just a dumbest
yeah
here we go
purple is i gonna make a purple light
nope it sure makes the hood look
disgusting let's change that
so like i guess the thing about fallout
4 and you can really tell that this game
is based or built on the same engine as
the previous games is that
so much of this idiosyncratic nonsense
that you remember from the previous
games is still here right down to like
glitches so like
talking to people is better
and you don't do that weird zoom in face
nonsense but like it's still broken in
like
unique ways
like people will just not be facing you
when you're talking
you're like straight up you're like
talking to the back of their head what
the hell was that
all right
all right case in point number one you
can pretty much free shoot in this game
pretty easily
which is way better than previous games
uh
also we had a second xbox one controller
plugged in and its vibrations just
scared the [ __ ] enemy
um
yeah so you can like in the previous
games trying to like do any sort of
aiming down sights especially with what
the hell was that
that a vertibird
i hear it but i don't see it
i don't know
well there's gunshots coming as well
yes you'll hear stuff a lot and just
i did they do a better job of this game
of like having firefights happen pretty
far away that you end up getting
involved in
which i like quite a lot uh but yeah you
can you can free shoot in this game a
lot better than you could in previous
ones
i will say that uh also we just leveled
up i do believe so to do that
i'm gonna hop in here
to the completely new perk system uh
this is
different to the previous game in that
instead of dumping all your
stuff into perks and then
leveling up uh i guess leveling up your
perks one to 100 and then
or leveling up your stats sorry 100 your
specials and then picking a perk
afterwards in this one you basically can
unlock anything at any time or you can
unlock perks and your special any time
so i've got an extra star here i can
just add it to any of these i can add it
to my overall perception my overall
strength is super shitty right now i can
just put a star into that right now or i
can use that same star to unlock one of
the perks
but the perks are only available based
on the amount of stars you have so in
intelligence for instance i've got a
bunch of stars there i'm up to one two
three four five six seven eight i
thought i had more than that actually um
and that unlocks all the level one
through i've got seven one through seven
perks so for instance if i was to like
min max on my first game and just set my
strength to 10 then i could instantly
dump a perk into paint rain which is uh
while wearing palm armoring sprinting
into m enemies hurts and staggers them
which is pretty good if you use power
armor
so yeah it's kind of weird you can you
can specialize pretty quickly so what
i've done at the moment is i have this
uh ability to uh sense the
weaknesses in um enemies during vats
i like to wander without companions a
lot so i get to carry a bunch more stuff
and i've got i take less damage i got
bloody mess
uh ranked up to two right now
three makes them uh
15
damage overall damage they take and then
four makes it so if somebody explodes
the person next to them might explode uh
i got black widow as well because i'm a
lady and i want to
kill dudes apparently
i need i can trick men if i do this it
goes up to the top it's pretty good
um
yeah and then the rest of it's all kind
of like you know your general medical
perks
uh
which i haven't really put anything into
so
i don't know what to put it in i don't
know which one to put in it
power hour isn't compulsory until
i will say it is not compulsory
there is a certain quest that i'm at in
the main quest which heavily implies
that you have to use power armor but you
can actually get away with not using
power armor in it as well so it still
has that sort of um
you know optional elements to you know
to mission
completion i'm going to dump it into
meta because i'm actually having a
little bit of problem with uh using too
many stim packs at the moment so i could
use a little bit of a boost there so the
weirdest thing about the start of
fallout 4 is that in the in the first
like
two hours of the game
everything that happened in the trailer
happens
so they front load you with everything
like you've got power armor within the
first two hours but the difference is is
that you've got crappy power armor and
you basically spend a lot of the game
upgrading your suit so i've got a power
armor back home and sanctuary which has
i got like no batteries for it's kind of
stuck there
and it also isn't like the best equipped
power armor in the game so
you kind of get it early but you don't
need to spend a lot of time upgrading it
i've also gone the wrong way i'm gonna
go this way
so where i want to go is
just up here to northeast
oh i see something flying i saw a shadow
where's the moon
so yeah at the start it's kind of weird
because they it's very fall eddy it
feels super especially like i've just
completed 403 in new vegas over the past
couple of months it plays very similar
to those
but it's only after and at the start
they like basically overwhelm you with a
bunch of
stuff like you fight a death claw within
the first like
hour of getting out of the vault which
is super strange you know because like
most people completed fallout 3 never
killing a deathclaw
so
in one way the first two hours was kind
of troubling but then
as you keep playing you realize that
like basically every system in the game
has been improved the combat's way
better the
like ability to really spec your own
persons better the exploration is really
interesting the characters are really
good so
it just kind of
it's like i think it has a sort of a
weird first impression and then
it really grows like i've basically
spent all weekend just loving the [ __ ]
out of this game
and there's so much to do which is
always a
good thing i also think it's probably
the best main quest i've only i'm only
like 10 hours in on this one
but i think it's probably the best main
quest of the the
3d series since fall including three in
new vegas because their main quests
weren't
super great like new vegas was better
but
uh it wasn't amazing someone's asking
can you get naked straight away you so
the the characters are wear way less
clothes now when they're not wearing
clothes than they did in the previous
game so if you're a dude you're super
topless
it's so weird that i know this uh but if
you're
a lady you're down to your skivvies as
well so if you want to
you can play a game like this
i'm not going to do that because that's
going to mean getting my face kicked in
where is my mask on
there we go
uh another interesting thing they have
in here if you hit start quick saves
right there bam which you'll be doing a
lot of
so they've straight up put the f5 button
right in front of you
uh
this is the door
we got one super mutant two super mutant
level 22.
oh man
all right
oh [ __ ] turn my light off
whoa see that see that guy glitch out
there
that's what fallout 4 is all about
but it's kind of funny sometimes
yeah all right
this is probably going to go real bad
so i'm going to quick save
and then try this
nope all right that's one the brute has
not been touched
there we go half his health
this other guy is just
stirring his pot like nothing's happened
he's like what are you all complaining
about
boom
i missed them for god's sake
all right
eat it
i don't want to waste any more of this
let's go with
i'm gonna go one shot i'll go with my
incendiary pistol how about that
this thing's pretty good
[ __ ] missed
yeah burn jerk
[ __ ]
let's do something at a bit more
distance
oh there you go headshot i'll do it
getting your own headshots is also
way easier like headshots in the
previous games were basically impossible
unless you were using vats
whereas in this they're at least
achievable
i have this thing where i'm stealing
every board game in the game so i'm
gonna have to take this chessboard
i don't think the bar games do anything
um most of the stuff you pick up in this
game as well has essentially used a
scrap
in your
oh here's a here's another place um in
your uh
uh yeah you can turn the vats off you
don't have to use the vats at all like
i'm i'm hitting a button to
make the vats execute
so
it's super optional
and we had a couple of the dudes oh i've
actually left here now let's go back in
um we've a couple of dudes in in the
office we're playing without using vats
at all uh which is possible but probably
not
ideal because the thing is like a lot of
the time you're surrounded by a bunch of
different people attacking you at the
same time or different like mole rats
all attacking you one time or like packs
of feral ghouls because they operate in
packs a lot more
and you kind of need the respite that
vats allows
and also the sort of like ability to
just finish something off that's like
super close to you
so you can
just play aim down sights the whole time
but like you really probably shouldn't
like you saw earlier with the ferals
like in it that would be a situation
usually where
you would you know
easily lean on vats just to get you
through it
where in this you don't necessarily need
to do that and it's fun like the [ __ ]
the in the inside is actually competent
it's actually like enjoyable
is this guy still cooking
this is a really good example of just is
he actually
yeah he's a bag all right [ __ ] human
head
that's a good example of the sort the
type of jank you get in fallout 4 where
it's not like game breaking or
you know
frustrated it's just kind of dumb
it's like it kind of it's like when your
dog just walks into like a glass window
like a glass door
where you're like you're just [ __ ]
stupid but like i still love you
you just kind of get used to it so
there's all these i'm sure there's gonna
be people like saying like oh man this
game's unfinished and like i think those
people probably never played a goddamn
fallout game before and if it was the
sort of thing where it really makes the
game unenjoyable and
like really takes away from it which i'm
sure it does for some people then like i
can get it but like most of this stuff
is so in the periphery that like you
just don't care
and it's kind of funny like that's kind
of funny right that this idiot was just
like
like just still stirring the pot even
though all his buddies are dead oh yeah
so they've got the mutants of dogs now
as well which are [ __ ] uh in fact
they've sort of like
rewrote like changed up a bunch of the
enemies like mirelurks now are [ __ ]
like disgusting and terrifying and
they're way harder to kill and they also
have babies
like bloat flies are still in it and
there's these new things that like suck
your
blood which i hate nice yeah this is
gonna give me
plus five percent damage against super
mutants sweet
so you pick up all the magazines like
before
you pick up
uh
you pick up a lot of interesting stuff i
kind of don't want to show you
necessarily because i don't want to
spoil it but you can pick up um
video games that you play on your
pip-boy
and they're pretty fun
ooh glow-sided heavy combat shotgun
oh i'm over-encumbered
all right i should probably go back to
diamond city and
sell some stuff
i got this irradiated rolling pin which
i think is my favorite thing in the game
it does 50 points of additional
radiation damage
so it just hit somebody with it
and it [ __ ]
it radiates them
okay i'm two over
which one of you
useless pistols i don't want to use
again is
muzzle power 24 17. this pi pistol is
terrible get rid of that
i think i had a quest in here maybe i
don't
oh this is the church this isn't the
plaza all right
okay for the sake of exploration uh i'll
see what's down here and then if there's
nothing good we'll go to diamond city
i guess not this way this way
yeah there's a lot of people talking
about how funny the game is there's a
lot of humor like there's always been
dark humor in fallout
like it's kind of like a dark you know
it's just a gritty awful reality
talking to people and blowing their
[ __ ] heads off straight away
so
like it's kind of
in that fail yeah burst tyrannosaurus
macklin makes a good point
ridiculous name if you want to play
something that's like
your super legit post-apocalyptic game
then the stalker series is right there
for you
whereas this this very much falls in
line with other fallout games
it's kind of dumb and i think you either
like it or you don't
i should probably not have this rolling
pin as my main gun
all right let's go to uh what you've
probably seen a lot in the trailers
which is
the main
i guess city in the in the
world at least what i've seen so far
which is diamond city which is
located in basically what fenway park
was back before the bombs drop
and there's some really good baseball
themed
and like socks themed missions in here
um i don't give any of them away there's
one more you're kind of like collecting
memorabilia like there's a guy in here
who
loves baseball he like he like tells
everyone about like
what this place used to be but his idea
of what baseball
is is like totally wrong
and
there's another dude who's like painting
the the big green monster at the back
this game also this city either looks
great or looks shitty depending on the
weather it looks kind of shitty right
now
yeah
also this pc isn't super great so it's
it's running okay
uh i've got running at home on altrum
and it's it's
very it's pretty beautiful it's not like
you know witcher 3 levels or anything
but it's it's right up there
so the back of it yeah
you can see him painting the
paint in the green wall back there
there's a quest to help him do that
which is pretty cool
uh one other thing you can't you can't
just wait anywhere anymore like skyrim
or like fallout 3. now you have to sit
down to do it so right now the shops are
closed
it's currently whoa it's currently crash
o'clock
fall fallout 4 what's going on
xbox one bundle really
follow our social media it's going to be
tweeted about uh that's interesting
that's the first time it's crashed on me
um actually no i've had a crash at home
once
um
where same thing boom straight up power
crash but that's in like
whatever 17 hours of play probably uh
we've just installed it on this machine
so
uh the first time i played it was when
we loaded up so
there you go
ain't good for
for some people out there uh we've not
updated the drivers or anything on this
graphics card so
who knows
there you go it's fallout game confirmed
just crashed while i was
wandering through a city doing
absolutely nothing
he can spin things
he can hit x to do that which turns a
different color
that's something i don't know
this is what they added in skyrim you
remember
we could move them
because people were getting bored with
the loading times
loading times ain't that bad on my
machine either at home they're a little
bit long here they're all so long on the
consoles on the xbox one i played maybe
10 errors on the xbox one and the xbox
one is
got some decent
oh you see that vertibird flying over
where is he
[ __ ] missed him again
all right let's try that again
don't crash this time diamond city
be great if the rest of the stream was
just again crashing over and over again
can you still physically pick up things
you can let me try it
in fact you can pick up bodies a lot
easier in this than you could
um in the in three or in
the various oblivion elder scrolls games
yeah they're they don't weigh as much so
let me try let me try to do that okay
it's looking a little bit better here
hope it doesn't crash again um
all right i'm gonna try and pick up
something that's not like
going to get me in trouble
okay here this box
nope
all right this thing so if i hold down a
there you go
pick it up
you can pick up bodies a lot easier
which i like
because i like picking up bodies all
right
so if i want to wait now you got to sit
down somewhere you got to find somewhere
to sit down
then hit what oh no don't talk to the
[ __ ] yes
sushi selling
ramen selling robot
all right two hours away for the stores
to open up
uh are the only critical hits from
charging up that bar as grif2501 yes so
there is now a crit bar on the bottom
of the screen there you can see this
guy's probably not going to be happy i'm
testing this down on him uh so when that
charges up to to its max
then you can you have the choice to
unleash a quit so you can hold on to a
crit if you're on you can just bank on
it but yeah essentially that is now the
only way to quit which is uh
interesting it certainly makes a big
difference to
perk development use which used to very
much be about increasing your chance of
credit
i'm sure there's things you can do to
increase your
i guess
the crit bar going up
uh all right let's sell some [ __ ]
yeah that pistol look anything that's
pipe pistol i usually sell
this combat shotgun i'm going to keep
i'm going to sell my other two shotguns
where are they
get rid of you
the laser musket you get pretty early on
i kind of like it
any of the pipe guns are just like not
really worth your time i don't think the
sniper rifle was pretty particularly
good either
way does 44 damage which isn't super
great
this muzzled pistol
i might sell them
sell the fire one
i'm keeping my rolling pin god dammit
yeah this one looks not too great either
so you can see the stats you see the
weights like plus plus plus minus minus
minus that is
in relation to the one you've got
um
equipped
whether it's better or worse so it takes
a little while to get to especially with
the apparel because if you're like
swapping through these like this
pompadour wig doesn't say this flannel
t-shirt
gives you less damage resistance unless
whatever the hell that means than the
previous one but then
all the things you wear aren't just one
thing anymore you can wear things on
individual arms and legs so it's kind of
you have to spend some time with the
system to kind of
figure out what exactly they're trying
to ask you and the flare gun i use for
calling in reinforcements assassin's
creed style so i'm going to keep that
and i want that shotgun
this is a pretty good machine gun
actually i don't think i need any other
ones
i think i'll get rid of his pistol now
it's worth a lot though
hmm
52 all right
so i need 44s
what ammo do i need most of this game is
basically most of the purchasing i've
had at least has been
trying to pick up as much ammo as
possible
um especially in harco mode harco mode
is like ammo so hard to come by
that's a lot of ammo but whatever
buy get some more 44s
i got in the well enough 38 rounds
that's my 10 mil looking that's okay
and i guess i'll buy
yeah let's get all those shotgun shells
ooh fusioncore i actually need to buy
one of these
1000 that's a lot but whatever we're on
a stream
thanks arturo
all right
look at that this game can be pretty
some of the time it looks ugly is muck
like
look at this look at this dude
look at this guy's weird face
ain't too great like textures aren't
like super super clear
kind of okay but then you turn the
corner and then this [ __ ] happens you're
like yeah
this game's all right
i think the lighting really helps
give like this world some sort of
like
warmth and
depth which which i think is the main
reason i like playing on pc i feel like
the gig the war looks a lot flatter when
you're playing on on the console
uh we could take the take the elevator
up and then we'll get out of here
oh it's upstairs
so the the the mayor lives up in the box
so you got to go up and talk to him
every once in a while how does the
fairground work can you just keep
calling reinforcements as long as your
flares um
i haven't used it that much
but if you're stuck you basically i
don't want to get into spoilers about
why but you can call in people to help
i'm pretty sure you can't do it
immediately again because
they're already there
but so i think it's the same
people that come back in
it's quick save so only one slot
yep over over uh writes the other one
although you can save you can hard save
after the quick save
and i believe the quick save is still
there so it overwrites the same one but
it doesn't
it doesn't disappear after you save
again look at that
look at that
fenway's looking all right
i'll just kill them all
all right let's show let's see a
different part of the world maybe let's
have a look at uh
yeah let's have a look at something else
bird makes a good point lighting looks
great textures look pretty muggy gives
the modders if you give the modders a
few weeks
it's just very true
i'm sure we'll get some high-res texture
packs eventually
uh okay where'd it go
i haven't explored much of this part of
cambridge around here so how about we
head up to college square and then go
east and see if we run into anything fun
uh yeah draw distance is good it's the
draw distance is good and i think the
biggest difference i felt in in
exploring the wasteland especially the
open areas is that the
the draw distance and fallout 3 in new
vegas was good but you couldn't there
was nothing like objects wouldn't come
in for a long time and there wasn't that
many of them whereas in this there's
like a lot more
like half dead trees a lot more
dilapidated buildings in the distance
you can see
so i think
it kind of feels like there's more going
on which uh which i like because at the
start it's weird because it feels less
desolate but then
it also kind of i don't know
feels more alive
all right
i got some ferals here
level and there's a fragmentation mine
level three
one shot and probably do this guy
see this is something you'd never do in
the previous game especially not with a
key what a controller
like i wouldn't be
taking pop shots of a feral goal this
far away
oh killed by his own mind
beautiful
i'm gonna shoot this fragment actually
because uh the car explosions are pretty
great [ __ ]
[ __ ] hell
yeah there you go
look at that body flying across
like the same
technology that made makes all the bugs
is the same technology that made that
dumb ass feral ghoul fly through the air
so that's kind of where i'm all right
with
the jank
like just [ __ ] stupid funny stuff
happens all the time
oh and radiated
hey what's up
how did you miss two of them
oh god damn it
and there's a lot more environmental
kind of stuff you have to worry about
like they have all the usual traps but
then like see these chimes
if i like walk into them people will
hear they also have these weird like
they're like children's toy teddy bears
that
uh you know clap cymbals and stuff when
you walk past them and the uh
the super mutants in this part of the
world have decided to use those as like
like
like proximity sensors so all the super
mutant places have
like all these [ __ ] teddy bears with
with drums and symbols and stuff dotted
around them
so you're just like creeping in and
suddenly one of these stupid toys goes
off and you're like oh damn it and then
all the super mutants know about it
which is pretty good
all right here we go can you permanently
miss bobble heads like in fallout 3
all of the bobble heads i've seen so far
have been in places that you can go back
to
so i don't know
um ever in fact i haven't been to a
place yet which i can't go back to i
don't think
including the original vault you start
out in
or you you you know what you emerge from
or whatever
and there's a lot at the start you pick
up a couple of bobble heads and a couple
oh god
just hanging out
and a couple of uh oh
one of my favorite things to do is to
shoot their legs off
par example oh just [ __ ] someone
there
[ __ ]
all right let's try a different gun
let's try this new shotgun i got
no great miss
oh yeah if you stand on things as well
people are idiots
like i killed in it i killed an entire
i killed a yao guai by just standing up
on a
branch and
shooting at him for like two minutes
at least they were able to hit me
if you shoot them in the legs as well
they kind of
stumble and fall over um i've shot one
once i blew both his arms off and then
he was still like coming after me what
the [ __ ]
hey lady
that'll do it
uh rob handler he has a video going up
of some of the
vats
assassinations like
a montage of it going up uh later today
and it is the funniest [ __ ] thing
some of the
some of the vats kills in this game are
just like so funny um i think at the
moment i'm only playing on hard
i'm on normal actually let me stick up
the hard
i've done survival i think very hard
might be the way to go because survival
is kind of dumb
survival isn't like hardcore mode in new
vegas so you don't have to eat things um
you don't have to sleep i don't think
companions can die in that mode either
um but it's just all it does is make
ammo scares
um it more difficult to kill you take
more damage you give more less damage
and also the amount of like epic
enemies that you come across has
increased significantly as well
so what you end up doing in survival
mode is like
not getting into fights which are not oh
[ __ ]
both arms
all right
yeah so what you end up doing is
avoiding
gunfights which is like the least
you know it's the most fun thing to do
and fallout is to get
like
pulled off to one side wait did i not
quit i'm pretty sure i quick saved after
that
weird i mustn't i thought i did
yeah i killed him in one shot that time
out for the mine
oh [ __ ] you didn't hit it that time
yeah that's another thing they do is
they do a lot of like jumping towards
you oh for [ __ ] sake you're gonna miss
all of those really
yeah no scope
boom
there you go
where'd that mine go
right there
oh [ __ ] i ran past one
you can still disarm them
as well all right i'm going to walk
around then i don't want to do all that
stuff again
i'm going to do quick save
and there was a question in there about
vehicles i have not come across any
vehicles you can use yourself except for
the power armor if you want to count
that
which you shouldn't because it's not a
vehicle so i'm not sure why i said that
uh there are flying things in this world
oh [ __ ] yeah why
level 16. i could probably take you
why do you keep missing lady what's
[ __ ] going on
there we go
yep keep shooting
you want to keep you up reload your gun
oh jesus christ
all right the only way i killed this guy
before was by jumping onto something
where he couldn't get me god damn it
where's that shotgun going
yeah cheez-it
hey protect the tron do you want to help
there's a protector challenge just
hanging out over there
oh that delicious cheese
you idiot
[ __ ] was that
thanks for helping protect the tron
let's go in here
uh so these red rocket things are all
over the place with power armor stations
it's where you find your
your doggy
you might remember in the trailer
so you can still work on stuff here make
armor
there's a lot of place for you to make
food as well which actually
um
helps a lot the cooking stuff they added
that new vegas obsidian it so that's
something that
bethesda at least one of the things
they've taken from new vegas and it's
good because basically like by cooking
the stuff you sort of
take the radiation out of it so you can
you end up like making mole rat burgers
which don't necessarily give you
you know a bunch of radiation which is
pretty good
all right
see what that protector tron has to say
for himself
collegiate administration building hey
what's up buddy
what's going on
all right
you said it
so i've not been to any of this part of
town
in fact we haven't even gone that far
we've only just gone that far in that
time so i'm going to keep going east i
might come back to this building if we
don't come across anything uh
interesting on the way
good old protector try
yeah yeah if you have any more questions
shoot him on in there
i'm watching the gamespot chat in the
twitch show right now
i already showed off my perks a little
bit so you can scan back on the video if
you wanna look at that
yeah mostly cambridge is pretty
pretty quiet
this is a cemetery which is never a good
thing there's a bunch more cemeteries in
this game as well
as you can imagine
and they're usually full of ghouls so
ooh hospital
nothing bad could be going on in there
flaming head
all right i'm gonna go in this hospital
if nothing else it'll be full of stim
packs
i see you're playing in first person
mode how is third person and why first
person
third person is kind of like it feels
like
the
um
feels like the only reason they show it
so you can like have a look at your
character every once in a while like
you'd never really play the game in
third person it's kind of like
i don't know i'll do a little bit of
this in third person you can kind of
come to your own conclusions
so how much people got to play it
already i think
like also in the games price a bunch of
youtubers and streamers i know had it as
well for the past couple weeks uh folks
asking to see all the armor and weapon
enhancement stuff and i'll do that in a
little bit actually i'll go back and
show you sanctuary where you can do all
your building
yeah so i don't know it's so much of the
game is based around like precise
movement and sneaking that i just don't
like doing it in
in this mode
terminal games are pretty
similar
one likeness r-u-l-e or u-l-e or u-l-e
or u-l-e-u
are you ally
all right
if you can never pick it just back out
and go back in
again deal
one so not that one maybe this one
same one
kept
kept
no all right
i want to see what's in this room yeah
sometimes it zooms in as well
so i think you can do you can do on the
pip boy as well if you want to
bore yeah
yeah exactly that's how i'm feeling
of course if you find the little um
brackets you can use those as well to
remove
possible
answers or add new ones oh [ __ ]
hey sorry about your legs oh [ __ ] that
didn't let me in there at all that's
amazing
this [ __ ] open door open wall on the
other side
take that raider scum
i don't want your pool cue
jesus
body's falling down what type of
hospital is this
all right let me throw something i think
i've got molotovs
oh [ __ ] let me try that again
no
well this place is really on fire now
boom
[ __ ] turrets
all right let me show you a different
weapon then
uh
let's go frag grenade and
what was that gun i got earlier
ooh the tactical musket you haven't seen
that yet this thing's pretty funny
especially when used in close range
you get this pretty early on as well you
can charge it once or you can charge it
a second time which gives it more uh
more oomph
i've almost got my crit as well
oh yeah i got you in the face
so you can charge it once or you can
crank it a second time and it basically
gives it more
power
[ __ ] he's got 100 he's got a lot of
health
are those exploding barrels
nope
hey what's up
oh i've got a crisp watch this
quick time
boom
so most of the time when you do a crit
it does like this sort of uh
cinematic angle but i don't think it did
there because i was just
stuck in a bunch of
gun foot like i was getting shot while i
was doing it and all that this head is
just floating there so i can just pick
up that head if i want
just put it on the table
beside this sweet pack of cigarettes
and like
you picked up a lot of crap in the old
games but in this one
you have a sort of uh
like a use for it this time so all the
junk you have you can
put into your general
um
[ __ ] hell go away
you can use back at your base so you can
just
store all your junk there and then
essentially use it to uh
add to your base like build stuff to
like upgrade and all that sort of
madness
uh we're also doing a fallout 4 xbox one
bundle
uh you should know tomorrow i believe
yeah will that be on the lobby or is
that going to be on twitter it's game
spot wide can we just follow follow on
twitter i'm guessing for that bad boy
for more information
uh
this [ __ ] terminal better die soon
enough there we go
all right take one more stim pack
and besides elements are there any
player homes yes there are you can
oh let's use the armor workbench oh [ __ ]
i can't because i'm fighting people
hey lady hey lady hey lady oh [ __ ]
come back
boom
only joking i only needed one shot
yeah you can buy homes as well the
settlements are kind of like
not super fancy houses
obviously because you're building them
yourself for 2000 caps you can buy
a house in diamond city i know that
so this is a weird thing with the
projector trons you can basically uh
activate them if you want but you can
also choose what personality they have
so cops will come fight you
construction workers basically don't do
anything i don't know if the medical
responders like heal you or something
let's try that out actually
so you can set them as a medical
responder and then
activate
units let's see what happens
hey what's up
please
can you heal me
electric arms
oh is he like a
he's like a first responder
that might not be good he might still
attack me or he might go around trying
to resurrect everyone who's dead i don't
know
that wouldn't be good
yeah third-person thing yeah it's just
it doesn't i don't like it i don't like
playing a third person they put it in
there as an option like you can if
nothing else it allows you to like
cinematically like look at your
character and stuff like that but i
don't really think the game is meant to
be played this way
like it never has you know it's not the
first time they've had third person in
it
like in skyrim they made it a little bit
more bearable they tried to say you
could play it than that but like
i don't know you know what it is i bet
it's like racing games i bet it's like
there is a certain population of the
game playing world that plays their game
a very specific way and that's like a
big problem racing game developers have
where they have to like cater to
everyone with all these like very
idiosyncratic or very like particular
ways of playing and i bet there's a
certain amount of people who play the
fallout series like this and they need
to
they need to be listened to what is this
blowtorch
yes please
is that a weapon or
just a thing
just the thing i got these boxing gloves
never used them
i've got one i've got one boxing glove
they used to be guy in the ufc used to
fight with one boxing glove
a synth
what could that be
uh if you've seen any of the trailers
you should you're probably aware
that synths uh are a big
plot device in this game i don't wanna
get into it anymore but
you end up fighting a lot of them
and fighting alongside some others maybe
you like third person bunch of people in
the chat like third person apparently
i don't know it's just not for me
can you do dual pistols i don't think so
unless there's a dual pistol
weapon in particular
but you can't dual wheels generally so i
don't think so
where the hell am i
is this back where i started
oh there's a turret
just walk around that turret
take this single bottle cap
blow up that turret
i like taking parts of the turret
because they tend to be usable
elsewhere right wait arrest you jerk
holes
whenever there's raiders i'm always
super worried about traps
they always set trip wires and
stuff like that you can kind of keep
tapping vats to
get an idea
oh [ __ ] a lot of sense down here
so f5 doesn't quick save i think it
still does yeah it does yeah f5 still
quick saves
this head situation
look at his arm situation
can't pick up the arm that's a shame
there we go
yeah bodies are lighter
hey this guy's still dripping ew
what else we got
open this door
holy [ __ ] this place is big
all right i'm gonna need something a
little bit more long distance
um
let's go this sniper rifle i've never
really used let's give it a go
oh yeah this sniper was all right
hey buddy
[ __ ]
boom
oh yeah this thing's one shot and people
like it's going out of business
oh doggy
yes
almost killed it
[ __ ]
i'll just beat you with the rest of it
this is a pretty significant cooldown on
the melee so you can't really hammer it
um
enemies tend to get a shot in
uh i'm on level all the the enemies are
leveled they don't level with you or any
of that nonsense
i think they bethesda got rid of that
idea a while ago but bottle cap mine yes
please
um
but that means that basically i think
what i've run into here is like an early
level area of the game
legendary raider eh
eat grenade
he's not dead
there you go
i'll just take a stim pack so your rads
now um
they
take away from your overall health so
you can see my health in the bottom left
corner that little red smidget there
that's the amount of rods that i have
so your your top level health is
basically
what it sort of dents into
there's plenty of rat away and rad x
like in the previous games for rad
defense and rad resistance and for oh
hello
yeah these guys are level one let's
shoot this guy's leg off
gonna shoot your leg off
ah didn't come off
oh jesus
there we go
crazy lady
all right
usually the thing that gets me out of a
place like this is like a real good safe
or something um i recently spent time in
a building which was very much like this
but the basement was just full of
high-level stuff that i was not prepared
for when i went down there
it was basically like a boss fight
situation
uh which is pretty cool but it's le it
left me without like i used so much
ammunition and
like so many stim packs trying to
survive that
i think i'm a little bit gun shy
coming into this
and in here
oh advanced lock it's a good thing i
could do them
jesus
must be up here then
what are the odds
there you go
and so lock picking
determined by your perk chart a lot of
it
so my lock picking right now is
um it's only on the first one
so i can do advanced then it's expert
locks master locks
and then your bobby pins don't break so
i've got one on that one and the general
hacking one as well
oh [ __ ] all right no more
sniper rifle let's go for
ooh pool cue
let's do that
hey what's up
bam
ooh two stint packs actually probably
could use
those all right
what else is that here
oh small picture frame i'll take that
[ __ ] turret
let's go with
i like the incendiary pistol
where is this jerk
i don't think there's any more reason to
go in there actually
i can't find my way
the way out necessarily maybe it's up
here
i guess i could just come back the way i
came in
i kind of want to move on and show you
guys something else
so let me just do that
unless i can go in here is that another
one
ah so close
there we go
sweet
surgical tray with pre-war money on it
and all the bottle cops i could ever
want
and more explosion explosives
all right let's get out of here
seen enough of this
hospital so-called hospital i love that
though i love how like this place has
just completely fallen through there's a
bunch of buildings in this
city where this has happened who the
[ __ ] was that
who said that
any more questions keep them coming in
is the carrying capacity larger than new
vegas for three it seems like you're
carrying a [ __ ] on already and my
strength is actually super low so i
shouldn't be carrying that much
um
i do feel like
so weapons for instance ammunition
doesn't weigh anything in this which it
did in three and didn't in new vegas
unless you were playing a hardcore mode
um i think that
i don't pick up a lot of
clothing which probably helps a lot with
my overall weight
um and then
the junk stuff doesn't weigh anything
like i guess it didn't in the last game
either maybe more stuff is junk now
uh but not general oh [ __ ] oh yeah he's
just hanging around what's up protector
tron
i'll be getting out of here now
so i i don't know like maybe i'm just
better at managing encumbrance because
i've been playing a lot of fall games
recently i haven't necessarily
realized that but you know what someone
out there is probably going to crutch
the numbers and find out um
otherwise leave the legendary bodies ah
i don't like they're like
low-level dudes i'm not going back in i
want to show you guys more stuff
the misalignment all those weapons
you'd be over on comfort for days yeah
totally
all right
where else shall we go
sure okay actually you know what let me
go back to where you start out which is
sanctuary
uh which is a little village oh there's
enemies nearby where
where'd a nearby enemies video game
are they here
can i travel now
sure can uh so sanctuary is the first
um
i guess like little
managing village you get the settlements
you get to
manage so
it's a place where there's a bunch of
buildings you can destroy and build on
their plots and
you have a number of civilians who are
living there
settlers that you can send there if
you're wandering around the wasteland
you meet people you can send people to
your settlements
and you need to provide them with
defense and water and power and all
those types of things
and then once you have the settlements
you can actually manage
trade routes between them so i've got
a bunch of things here
i've got different workshops actually
with different
things as well sanctuary hills ten
pounds bluff for the two
settlements i have the truck stops where
you meet your dog
and i got this lady trash can carla
carla what's up trash can
time to do business yeah don't worry
about turning to talk to me
what kind of stuff do you have just a
bit of everything you'd be surprised
what people leave behind oh trashcan
you crazy loon
let's see what you have yeah yeah keep
your shirt on
let's see what you're selling oh she's
sucking a lot of ammo actually
might bite a 308 off her
oh she got a lot of weapons
surprising
and of course drugs and a dictal is
something you take to get off of being
addicted to buffett or mentats or jet or
whatever which i think is new i think
you only you had to go to a doctor
before
oh i'll probably take those bobbies
actually
yeah so these people live in your little
world here and then basically
if you hold down the
menu button on the xbox one or the view
button sorry
you open up this thing
which basically allows you to scrap
items in the world you can straight up
scrap entire houses not not all the
houses but some of them
so you're going to get steel from
scrapping that car i'm going to get wood
from scrapping up
picket fence
and then with this
with all this scrap you build stuff so
this is a house i built earlier
it's got a sweet
basketball thing outside it's got like
no walls it's just a bunch of beds with
paintings on the walls right now
and i guess the use for this stuff is
that
up at the top of the screen you'll see
there's a happiness meter 58 it says
that's based on everything that i've
done so see there's 10 beds there's
enough beds for everyone there's 10
defense i have turrets at the front of
the uh
at the front of the settlement
i have no power yet i have to do that
i've got water i've got some water pumps
here
which apparently have non-irradiated
water i've got some more water pumps
over here and then i've got a couple of
different gardens so there's melons
razor grain i built some more over here
so they're not happy with the food yet i
don't think
some of the food isn't working out too
good
this one requires a gardener a farmer
does it maybe i don't know
you can set people to do certain tasks
i can just scrap this jungle gym if i
want
and i've got defense at the front my
defense is pretty rudimentary
scrap that car
i'll keep that cooking station um yeah
defense at the front is basically two
outposts which at the moment nobody is
manning so i need to man those and then
i got some uh
some turrets here as well
um
can you
stick
stick it npcs as in kind of can i kill
npcs or can i what the [ __ ] are you
i have to get out of build modes to kill
this damn rad roach
using my super expensive incendiary ammo
um you can put npcs in those positions
and then you can also send npcs into
your village so if you're like for
instance i met like a guy who was
being pro like a do you remember in the
previous game super mutants would often
like
basically turn humans into slaves so i
saw a band of super mutants walking
around with a slave human if i killed
all the super mutants then i would have
freed him
and then he could have come and lived
in any number of my sanctuaries also you
can i don't need any stoves i'm gonna
get rid of these also you can send your
uh
your friend your um companions here as
well so i can send dog meat here or
nick valentine or any of the other
uh many companions i think there's
something like 10 companions you can get
in this game
i'm gonna use my irradiated rolling pin
on these guys
bam
get a sick crit
oh can you have sexual intercourse with
npcs no but thanks for asking i don't
think so anyway i've not been playing
the game that way maybe there's some
like unlockable
conversations with dog meat you can have
i don't know
i'm sure someone will mod it guys
so you can build
prefab structures
uh and what's interesting is if you go
around the world you pick up these like
ikea catalogs which give you new
versions of these to build uh including
this which is straight up like a house
like this is just a house you can you
can build that
um i think there's probably ones for
wood as well
so if i go over here
yeah look here's a house there's a house
made of wood
bam
where's the front door of this wood
house
does it have a front door
who needs front doors here it is all
right
so i'm going to rotate it a little bit
like this whole ui is a little bit
cumbersome for this to be completely
frank as you can see
so i'm going to put that there
that's a sweet looking house
you know what a house needs though
needs me to not look at it while i press
b apparently
it needs
a door
look at all these doors i can have
which there you go that's better
red door i like this red door
and look i got myself a house
this one's got an upstairs
this is where you hide the bodies
oh it's got a it's a balcony situation i
quite like this
how quaint
so this whole like
area here
uh is pretty
like ru
it's not really required i i don't think
from what i talked to peter anyway about
completing the game and my time playing
it it's not really required it's super
optional and there's a question in there
asking uh grumpy your face man when can
you build slash start bases is it
straight for me off it is like
remarkably close to the start of the
game
like if you power through the intro it's
within the first like
hour maybe but it's it's realistically
it's within the first two hours
it's right after you do all the power
armor stuff so with my power armors up
here actually i better check it out
yeah it's pretty dark at night time it's
probably darker on the stream though
knowing how
this stuff usually looks
here we go
into the power armor
so i can upgrade all these different
face plates
once you're in it you can see my
cord there has only got
like a four battery left i think or
something
or four cores
a little bit of battery left so you can
walk around in this thing
use your irradiated rolling pin and look
like a badass
uh good gets good radiation
protection and stuff like that
oop that's my light
but i haven't been using it much at all
so
yeah yeah it has that light on it
so you can do weapons workbench here you
can add
mods to your various
guns if you want you can remove mods
quick eject magazine
stick a bayonet on this thing
because i've got adhesives screws and
steel
and then the other thing is i guess this
is your general workbench here to the
right so this is where if i hit x here
i'll just say store all junk so i got
245 in encumbrance right now if i store
all junk like it's down to 199 and that
basically takes off anything that's
like oh i want the grenades back
but anything that's like just random
stuff
and it'll it'll drop in there
so it's pretty good
so we basically use all that stuff to
you can filter through it or you can use
it to build stuff usually use it to
build stuff but
what's this [ __ ] idiot doing hey
sheffield
sheffield
what do you think about coming to work
for me
thank you
he was a bum in diamond city who i gave
a can of nuka cola to and now he lives
with me
so be careful here you give cans of
nougat too
and he said to map scale are there more
billings to enter
it doesn't really feel like there's that
many more billing center it feels in
line with other fallout games
uh it's pretty big though it felt small
when i started because you get down to
diamond city so very quickly
but it actually is the space in between
where you're going between places
actually has a lot of things in it
what's this i've never been in here
university point
maybe let's try and get down there
what's the closest thing to it maybe so
that's a freeway so
all right i've never gone there so let's
let's try and wander into that part of
town
we'll be in the south end of boston
walking out
do you have your stuff equipped to use
as your weapon bench or kind of come out
of your storage do you have
to store
your stuff equipped
the bench is basically used for only
modding
so
generally when you're storing things so
the the various settlements don't have
shared storage so you can't put
something in one and then get it out of
another
um as at least the general stuff is like
the workbenches and whatnot so
generally there is no magic place to
store things that where you can get it
from everywhere uh you just have to have
it on your person
at least that's what i've experienced so
far anyway i've been very much a all
right stuff that i need i'm holding on
to my myself
stuff i need for the settlement like
fusion cores or
you know junk i'll bring back there and
stuff that i don't want i basically find
the nearest
specialist seller and try and sell it to
them
there's a lot more forests
as well like a lot like the grass here
seems to be doing all right
there's a lot more stuff growing around
as well like far more than three in new
vegas
ew hey doggie
are you friendly
teddy
sure i'll unlock you teddy
i did see a guy who was selling dogs
earlier
he said at least he told me he was
selling dogs
but it wasn't this dog it was a lady dog
what's going on teddy
what's up
what
oh [ __ ]
yeah help me teddy some [ __ ] you
[ __ ] don't you
i just [ __ ] saved that dog you jerk
i'm gonna crit him
what
wow i never did that before
you killed my dog you jerk
oh
i'll take your bandana
so i can always remember you you [ __ ]
jerk
oh
that's so frustrating
man all right where's my shotgun i'm
gonna i'm gonna take out my aggression
on some
some jerk holes
there we are
so you can hop you can stick these on
your
little hot swap
d-pad situation if you want who the
[ __ ] doing that
oh you're there
just allow me to stim pack before i
murder you
oh lady
nope
i'll be taking that
[ __ ] dog
what was it eating
brahm meat that doesn't seem right would
you feed a regular dog a cow
that seems weird
all right we're gonna make our way south
and this is still my favorite thing
about fallout is just
exploring deciding on a
spot in the distance and just
slowly making your way towards it
and then getting distracted the whole
way on the way
are the stamp packs on a quick button or
did you have a favorite i haven't
favored it
so i've got a favorite on the bottom
here on my bottom of my uh
my little d-pad thing
oh [ __ ] hell
man mole rats in this game are no joke
there's like a bunch of more different
types like this glowing [ __ ]
oh
brood mother
[ __ ]
star war or starcraft
come here
they also go on the ground which sucks
because then you don't know where to
kind of come up again and they follow
you forever i tried to run away from a
pack of mole rats yesterday and man
[ __ ] off
yeah kid it again
ah
i'll beat you to death
beat your head off
exterminator's flamer what
this mole rat had a [ __ ] flamer
fifty percent more damage against
mirelurks and bugs oh i'm gonna enjoy
using that against mirelurks
we should probably find a mirelurk
they're no joke in this game either
they're way harder
and they also have babies there's like
baby
mirelux all over the place tower status
inactive extend satellite alright yeah
sure whatever
all right
what's going on
what'd i do
this is probably a quest i've not done
any of
ooh
new distress signals super mutants radio
oh you got to be i gotta listen to that
there's a lot more radio in this game as
well
diamond city radio has got the most
boring dj in the world and there's an
amazing quest around that
there's a distressed signal
i can't actually hear it out here but
let me go what's the superman broadcast
like
you can still walk around and listen to
the music as you go
man i love that that's like there's
probably like a bunch of quests going to
come out of that stuff now as well
and the freeways are all still falling
over as well
yeah people who say this game looks like
fallout 3 or editor mind like that they
need to go back and play fallout 3
like it doesn't look like this is not by
any means the best looking game of the
year it's not in the top
like 20 probably
legendary albino mongrel
jesus christ
but it looks fine you know but it
definitely looks better than
like fallout 3 like no idea how
how little like environmental content
there is in fallout
3. and look i can oh [ __ ] i didn't know
my health was low damn it
ah
the radio signals might get stronger
actually the closer you get because
that's true actually i might be part of
that quest they also drop out and drop
in a lot more
yeah which is true
and yeah they're probably going to mod
the crap out of this as well damn i hope
i got that before i say before the
flamer or after the flamer
oh my god it's my chance to avenge you
i'm gonna kill those hunters before they
get involved
beautiful
all right where are you jerk holes
i know you're close
unless you just spawned when i
got doggy
teddy he's got such a cute name oh
do they just appear when you kill the
[ __ ] thing that can't can you open it
there's like no one here right i'm
clicking vats
over and over again
and i don't see anyone
anyone over here
no
we're good okay just me and teddy good
don't worry teddy
you'll be out of here soon
once the game allows me to unlock this
door
there we go
it was up here last time
no maybe not
yeah and console mods as well that's
going to be interesting
a little bit more a little bit more
oh [ __ ] i woke up this morning and my
girlfriend had a bunch of bobby pins
laid out on a table and i almost picked
them up
oh [ __ ] hell
there we go
all right you [ __ ] i knew it
no way do you take bobby this time
boom
i got one more left for you lady and
it's a crit
yeah teddy wants some of the action
teddy i saved
you ungrateful jerk
where are you going
where are you going
you don't know what to do now do you the
only thing you wanted to do in life was
kill those raiders and i did it for you
go
live free
enjoy your life teddy
i give teddy about two minutes before
he's dead
i'll be taking those
i love going up to random parts of
people and then using them
to pick things up like that's cool right
like there's a lot less [ __ ] in
playing the game because you just walk
up and then you can flick through things
and decide if you want them or not
so it's like one less button click
throughout the entire game which is
pretty good
yeah they're pretty
teddy's pretty independent really
all right i'm going to do that relay
station in a little while
i don't want to repeat a bunch of stuff
for you guys
let's keep going down here
gotta be careful when you're running of
course because it takes away your
your uh vats juice your ap down the
bottom right
so if you're running a lot and then you
come across somebody you might actually
uh
you might not have enough vats juice
to fight them properly i'm staying the
hell away from there
super mutants in this game are no joke
they're like actually difficult
they're like way higher level most of
the time so you need to like
keep a bit of distance between you at
least until you've leveled up like i'm
level
what am i level 13 right now or
something
who's down there
mr gutsy
whoa what the [ __ ] was that
what the [ __ ] was that
did anyone else see that
was that just me
wouldn't anybody else see that
there's some weird uh oh [ __ ]
oh mr gutsy ain't happy
jesus christ he's gonna kill me isn't he
maybe not the brightest place to
quicksave
[ __ ]
that was like a nuclear
it was like a nuclear explosion
in the dist uh [ __ ] this
stem packs stem packs and running stem
packs and running are the best tactic
stem pack
stand back and keep running oh where's
that sniper rifle i had
jesus christ he's fast
because i've now got no
fats whatsoever
eat it cutty
jesus you missed oh god
i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry gutsy i'm out of here
great i found a high school can i
skateboard here
uh gore bags which means there's super
mutants around here
hopefully gutsy wants to fight them
do you say a teddy exploded in the
distance
that could be true whoa vertibird
yeah so the brotherhood of steel are
definitely way more
organized in
this part of the world what the [ __ ]
what is going on here
holy [ __ ]
i've never seen an end like this before
you guys shooting me
oh no you're shooting that guy
i'm not really part of the brotherhood
yet
there is an early quest whoa
dude just power armor dudes just jumping
down
[ __ ] hell
what the [ __ ] happened
there did a
did a nuke go off
okay we have to run back there and see
what that is
what was that
oh hey synth
i'm pretty happy i think this stream has
been a pretty good approximation of
what's good about fallout 4 it's just
like yeah it's just regular fallout but
then like in the distance some [ __ ]
insane gnarly [ __ ] happens you're like
what
what's that about
all right let's see what the [ __ ] let's
see what the [ __ ] that was again
chat's going crazy
all right quick say
i don't know i
to me that felt like an event
not like it's like not like a scripted
thing
but it could easily have been a scripted
thing it doesn't look like it's
happening this time
i mean i guess it's kind of cool if it
doesn't happen
but it'd be kind of cool if it did
happen
wow okay
oh my god
all right
i hear shooting again
it's the gunners this time it's not the
brotherhood
like how big was that explosion was this
thing like a
is it like a
did somebody fire off one of those
oh yeah that's probably it
somebody's got a fat boy jeez oh yeah so
there's another thing where a lot of the
super mutants wear suicide vests now
eat a gunner
i don't really know who the gunners are
yet of oh [ __ ]
jesus christ
stand back
jesus all right getting out of here i
know where i'm not wanted
yeah so like
it's still a game where like interesting
random things happen but
i guess they seem kind of more random
this time as well they don't feel like
like oh the players turned up let's make
some crazy [ __ ] happen i guess that was
kind of
that was like a
maybe it's like a dynamic scripted event
i don't know
all i know is i had to get the [ __ ] away
from there let's go in this church
nothing bad ever happens in church right
this [ __ ] still chasing me
what was that
oh man they're all kicked ooh can i get
in the vertibird
you guys fighting the brotherhood or is
that your vertibird
finish them off
him
oh [ __ ] there's someone to the left of
me
[ __ ]
these guys are too high level for me
i've got a rocket launcher but i can't
all right [ __ ] this
where's my rocket launcher we got to
make it we got to see if we can do this
where are you son of a [ __ ]
where'd you go
dammit
oh you got to be kidding
what the [ __ ] is it crap what this just
bounced off the ground
i got no more stim packs
oh for god's sake
oh
apparently missed him
oh you've got to be kidding all right
you know what
how the [ __ ] did i miss like maybe i'm
just like the worst shot in the world
or maybe you can't hit those things i
don't know come on we got i got to try
again i got a dragon
oh [ __ ] you know it's gonna be really
easy to hit it when it's sitting on the
ground
where are we at here we go
boom
hit it before you get up jerk
oh yeah it's definitely got health okay
oh i've got no more stimpaks left
i may be biting off more than i can chew
here
i can't i can vax i can bat it
oh this is so cool hit it
i hit it
one more
i'm not close enough to vats right now
come on come around come around
95 come on
is it going down
what the [ __ ] how did i not kill you
oh my god it's still not down
oh you got to be kidding
okay okay we can do it we can do it
this is
it oh
hp i know i ain't got i've got no more
stems
all right so we gotta do here
first things first
let's sort out the aid
problem i'm gonna eat some mac and
cheese
and then i'm gonna take some jet okay
no not yet we're gonna go
we're gonna go damage i got buffed yet
which slows down time for 15 seconds you
can combine the different drugs now uh
which is pretty cool i also got buff
tats
i guess i could take more
yeah what else i got here
check
jet jet is the if you don't know is the
thing that slows down time um psycho
allows you to resist damage so let's do
that
i do have a stealth boy but they're
going to see me
i'm sure
so let's
weapons
missile
there's launcher shot
boom
two shot boom
and then what i gotta do is
eat a bunch of random [ __ ] so
rad scorpion steak
rad roach meat
rat scorpion steak actually gave me full
health that's pretty good
so we can quick save again
where's this jerk
it's too far away
i'll wait for him to come back
come back here
come on you gotta get right underneath
me
boom
eat it
yeah [ __ ]
look at that thing
and stay down
jesus
yeah
can i pick up some of your stuff
any sweet swag in here
vertibird hide
ah all right
and that's gonna do it i think folks
shoot this gunner corporal while we're
here
oh you lucky summer [ __ ]
let's kill this guy
i'm crippled i'm crippled and i don't
care
boom
where's the where's the corporal at
[ __ ]
one of us has to die ah that's it
donna dusted
what's the shout from the production
room
we keep going
yeah [ __ ] it let's keep going let's keep
going we could we could end it we could
end the stream there but let's keep
going
i'm enjoying myself too much
a little bit more
uh
all right oh i didn't damn that ship yet
where's it gone
last time i saved it before i did d we
got to watch this all over again
somebody in the chat asks is this all
you do in the game
i mean
if it is
and you don't like it then you're
probably playing the wrong game don't
miss
boom
oh i love that shot i wonder if it ever
lands on you
look at that thing of beauty
all right i'm getting the [ __ ] out of
here
getting out of here
suffolk county charter school
oh so here's a weird thing right so oh
[ __ ]
that was way too much to kill him um
so there's like halloween [ __ ]
everywhere look at this
so there's like halloween stuff
it was like it seemed like there was
more of us the more oh [ __ ] there's a
super moon there's a bit is that a
behemoth
i think it is we're going to go kill
that behemoth um
so i think it i think the game knows
that it's like halloween right now and
it's like halloweening up the world
so we should like set this like pc to
like christmas day or something it might
it might be server side but look it's
happy halloween stuff and like people
are even saying to me in diamond city oh
it's halloween
which is pretty crazy
yeah that's a behemoth
okay
let's see what we're at
[ __ ] that i miss
boom
uh-oh uh-oh
whoa he throws rocks
[ __ ]
stop throwing rocks at me
can i get on the roof
is that a thing i can do is there a roof
here
i keep waking up waking up all these
guys
one down
two down where's behemoth
is he gone
where'd he go
this guy's freaking out
has he gone back to fighting them he has
all right let's i need to i need to set
this missile launcher onto one of my
there you go
55 i think i got a better chance just
doing it myself
boom
boom
oh [ __ ] up no more rockets oh oh
uh oh i gotta nuke mine
they're pretty good
[ __ ] i threw it too close
come over here
come over here behemoth man
keep coming stop throwing rocks at me
please
i'll just hide behind this tree
apparently
he's able to like spin them real good
come on come over here
on
what's he hitting
those nuke mines are like no
no joke
[ __ ]
if he lands on one of those things
they're they're gonna probably kill him
in one shot especially because i dropped
two of them by accident
bubblegum
uh i don't like taking the blowflight
meat because it's not as good as the the
steaks
yeah grilled rad shack there look boom
so the food that you make really helps
you out a lot more
oh god damn it come on come over here
because i can't run towards you because
i'm going to jump into one of my stupid
minds by accident
slowly but surely
slow and steady wins the race
[ __ ] it you know what where's that
sniper rifle
no that's his torso
boom
boom
where's your head
give me your head
yeah
all right now all i gotta do is find
those two nuke mines i put down
the problem is i put two of them right
beside each other so i'm probably gonna
have to disarm them
together
oh [ __ ] all right
there's one and there's two
goddammit
there's one
all right
let's see what's in our behemoth he was
not that difficult all things considered
deathclaw hand yes please i'll be making
the deathclaw
ooh a laser pistol
yeah i think there's a weapon there's a
quest for the shish kebab in this game
the shish kebab is a weapon in three
which is a flaming sword but i think
there's like a
weird quest around
somebody's like
long lost shish kebab or something
which is pretty cool i like that one oh
so your own minds hurt you now your own
minds always hurt you if you put them
down
um
you can disarm them
if you want but if yeah if you threw a
mind at someone and they were within
proximity of you they still hurt you so
yeah see halloween [ __ ]
it's all not in every building but it's
on like
you know community buildings and stuff
actually i'm not sure because
now that i think about it actually
there's halloween [ __ ] all over the
the starting area when you started so it
might maybe the i don't know
i don't think that the bombs dropped
around halloween for some reason i think
it's something to do with like the real
world
i guess somebody's probably already
figured that out these guys are
disgusting he's pink weirdos
i've got no more
ammunition for that guy though
got some 308s here
let's set these dudes on fire
so this is one of those stupid monkeys
that go off
and alert everyone you gotta shoot
stupid hat off
these all look like teachers
or students
ooh food paste
i love that
all right
well this machine does nothing i can
load holotapes in here as well i've got
a bunch of like
hollow tapes some of these are video
games some of them are
are
like scripts and things
let's play some space and babes
can you folks play the mothership zeta
expansion pack for three
uh there's five games in the world to uh
unlock to find
this is one of them
as advertised
space invaders
where's me after there was no like
space and there's no games in any other
games maybe it's just like part of the
rich heritage of video game development
and
oh here we go there's the dude
we're gonna get him
oh i missed him
this is next-gen baby yep this is that
games are in games within games
yeah it was a deathclaw weapon in three
the deathclaw fist could be turned into
a
pretty gnarly melee weapon
i think the best difficulty to play on
is hard
extra hard is fun survival like i said
is not oh [ __ ] is not a is not great
it's it's super hard but it's just it
takes like in that situation if we're
playing that in survival mode and you're
up against like a what the [ __ ] is get
away from my cat
oh minus 400. man they've
they've
changed up space invaders [ __ ] i'm not
gonna lose this on the last life am i
in the original space invaders they went
fast because the
uh
in the same way when you finish
solitaire on a windows pc like nowadays
it goes really fast yeah this [ __ ] this
was because of the
[ __ ]
the hardware at the time wasn't like
frame limited so it just like when it
had more processing power they'd go
faster it was like complete accident
[ __ ]
yeah oh [ __ ] that
yeah i'm done
was that a cow was it saying moo i
didn't know
so the thing about the holotapes is you
can also play them on the pip-boy so you
don't need to be at a desk to do it
um
let me show you one more
um i think i've cut out on this save
i've collected three of them i think
where are we at blah blah blah blah
that's a it's like a d game
i haven't actually played this one yet
but i'm guessing i know what it is
collect all the bobble heads before the
time runs out
yeah for those of you who
are too young to remember this is a oh
no i gotta jump over that thing
this is a pastiche of an old atari 2600
game
called pitfall
which
was [ __ ] hard if i can remember all
right
gotta get those bobble heads what's
going on here
yes swinging it
yeah video games give me a bobble head
video game
at least some health there
sure did i got a bobble head though
and so on
yes you can play a bunch in there it's
pretty cool
those games should be on ios in fact if
you have the
bizarrely enough if you have the fallout
app
which uh can be used to like
use your your pip boy
if you have the pip boy edition if you
don't have the pitboy edition it still
works you just don't have it in a
pip-boy so in fact it's a better
experience probably and if you do that
then you you can actually if you collect
the game you can
technically
i think as long as fallout 4 is running
on your console and you're near it you
can play those games on on the ios
hey dudes
actually i just got a freak shoot these
guys right you just
ain't so hard
i don't know why these ones are so pink
and naked it's kind of upsetting
oh yeah more food paste
it's gonna be some like food pace quest
that i don't know about
who knows
oh [ __ ]
i probably shouldn't be using this sweet
incendiary armor on these guys but it's
so much fun look at that
tin con these guys are useless
this school was full of idiots
naked red idiots
yeah what's this
look like a quest
so who knows maybe all that stuff will
have turkeys on it by the end of the
month ooh more food paste is that why
they're pink because they ate all this
food paste is that what's happened
have i just put two and two together
food pays
[ __ ]
i need to take
some aid
a little bit of uh
role model rap meets not good because
see the chops are the best one right
because then i'll fill you up
and it's got no radiation
all this food paste maybe i should eat
some of their food paste
are there ammo types uh there are not
there are ammo types in that certain
ammo only works on certain guns so 44
308 9 millimeter 10 millimeter all that
sort of stuff um you can't use
different announcement different than
items different uh ammo and different
weapons
the thing that makes this incendiary is
the gun so it's a modification on the
gun itself
uh i just picked up a little bit of a
holotape though school announcement
holiday let's have a listen
good morning teachers and students
it is a fabulous wednesday here at
suffolk county charter school
the glee club is having their seasonal
bake sale today so stop by and show your
support so we can send our team to the
regionals
remember actual baked goods are
forbidden on school grounds food selling
colorful cups for your food pace
oh also we will be having a school
assembly during second period tomorrow
on the dangers of strangers by jangles
the moon monkey himself jangles the moon
monkey
oh there's a [ __ ] i see you i see you
um i think i have a giant glow monkey
but he's probably back on my base now
yeah i think i dumped him off into
with all the rest of the junk
ooh a cooking pot
yeah i'll take your dirty water you can
combine three dirty water to make pure
water now not really sure how that works
but
whatever is that all that was in that
room really
geez
yeah i'm way too focused on uh
on the food pace oh so the bombs dropped
on october 23rd okay so it is probably
contextual
that's a shame i want this weird version
of this world where the date changes
every time you emerge from the vault on
a
different time in the real world
hey buddy
i'm gonna sleep
uh let me change to a different gun
there's a there is a park where you can
kill people silently in the in
while they're sleeping as well
which is the perk i i guess we all wish
we had really
shotgun shotgun shotgun
so that's a fun thing with with vats the
new vats is that if you
if you vats behind somebody you can
sometimes accidentally on purpose kill
the one in front
because it's all moving now so they can
like just get in the way
which is pretty good
also i think i just leveled up
huzzah
look how low my strength is
i kind of want to level up that last
charisma one
just to get to 10th be done with it
although bloody mess is so good
like
getting an extra 15 that's pretty that's
pretty brilliant
wow hassan says when he escaped the
vault the first time in three it was
during the night time that's actually
kind of weird
all right all right can you stop people
with the gun yes you can
and with the musket gun you can you can
use it to
it just basically like puts up there
i'm not gonna add it into anything
actually for the moment i'll wait till i
got another one
um
ah [ __ ]
i'm worried i'm just gonna dump it into
something wrong cause i'm not paying
attention
yeah i think it's just additional damage
on your meta is all it does
though i kind of want to do that the
locksmith one because i feel like expert
locks are going to start coming around
yeah
but then there's nothing ever any good
in the expert locks
except everything you ever wanted
i'll do that
i actually did come up to a an expert
lock
in the last building i was in that i
couldn't open and it kind of frustrated
me so
boom
i got a crit in my next shot
some poor purple bastard's gonna get
shot in the face real hard
elevators are boring they just bring you
back to the
start usually is there anything else in
here i missed
toy alien yes
toy rocket ship yes are these all
children that are like turned into
massive pink ghouls
this is the witcher i just use a [ __ ]
sign to push that over how do i get in
there
oh you got to be kidding me
oh can i load up my last save
put it into the hacker one
let's see when was this one
was that just after i leveled up god
damn it god damn it
i should have put it in hacking
yeah two lockpick
it's not cheating it's not cheating if
nobody says it's cheating
uh john asks final verdict does fallout
4 better than three
i mean
that's a big oh i'm back here no that
won't do that won't do that's too far
i just have to live with it um
like that's a big ask like it doesn't
have the impact of
three by any means like three was a
three is up there in the
best 2d to 3d conversions of all time
with like grand theft auto and
probably very few other games
uh i think this is a great game in its
own right oh fire watch this watch this
watch this
burn boy
sometimes there's like just random
petrol petroleum or whatever on the
ground
ah he's having a burn time i'm sorry did
you lose your leg and your arm as well
hey shall we kill him
boxing glove
punch him in the face
yeah so this is a very different game
for a very different time well actually
no sorry take it back it's the exact
same game for a very different time
uh i like it i like it a lot i think
it's great i don't think it has the
impact of three i don't think it'll live
in people's memories in the same way as
three but i think
uh
it's a wonderful game
it feels like new vegas in that it's
it doesn't seem radically different to
three
in many ways
but it doesn't matter
like vegas was
very similar in most ways to follow
three
and we were all just happy enough to
play more fallout and this kind of feels
like all right it's got a little bit of
a lick of paint
maybe it could have used a little bit
more paint but you know what
whatever
i'll take it all
is power his power armor better than
daedric
i don't know man wait for the mod to
come out i'm sure somebody's on that
[ __ ] right now
i can import your skyrim character into
fallout i just fall down and miss that
whole area
i just accidentally fall down and
end up downstairs again
i didn't go down oh i did go down
it's back here
head to the commonwealth
all right
uh let's see what's outside if there's
nothing crazy outside i'm gonna wrap it
up we've got a bunch of fallout features
going up on gamespot.com today we've got
a
settlement
building 101 we've got a video about the
video games that are in it and rob's
going to be posting that brilliant vats
montage thing later on
we've of course got the video review up
on gamespot.com
and 910 the written review as well
a bunch of features
that's sort of where you need to go to
pick up the best gear early on in the
game
and we got the intro cinematic up on the
site which is pretty good a bunch of
gameplay clips as well
if you uh are sick of watching this on a
stream maybe i wanted to see some
1080 60 stuff that's all there
yeah running on a
super fast computer as well
so uh no shortage of uh thought out
stuff
on gamespot today or indeed for the rest
of the week i'm gonna throw a [ __ ]
molotov at you jerks oh no it's a nuke
mine
well that did the job
all right
there you go the beauty of random events
in fallout 4. let's end it on that uh
thanks so much for watching today's
stream i really appreciate it like i
said a bunch more stuff uh about fallout
4 and everything else up on game spot
right now thanks to josh shot eric tay
darma horika and everyone in the back
for helping out with today's stream and
of course make sure if you're watching
on twitch to hit that follow button so
you can catch all the streams here on
twitch.tv gamespot and to you watching
on gamespot make sure you hit the logo
so you can go back to the homepage and
see all the hot new fallout 4 goodness
we got going on the site until next time
i'll see you then adios
you